dear inspector you are invited to attend
mr. White's annual masquerade party
formal dress and masks are required well
here we are I suppose I should find mr.
white and thank him for the invitation
oh that's me talking hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to murder
at masquerade Manor so it seems that we
were invited to some party or some ball
of some sort but unfortunately this
seems to be a murder that takes place in
here hmm very well Oh No
alas will someone murdered or through
yonder window I'm just being a little
melodramatic let me go find the source
of that sound where did the murder tee
oh my who's mr. white he's been murdered
oh no everyone here is a suspect why I
should speak to everybody to see if I
can find out who did this okay it looks
like he's been stabbed to death so I
should see if I can find the murder
weapon oh look here's a murder weapon
back though there's a murderer on the
loose hang on no one stabbed me in the
back with this knife it's covered in
blood hey what are you doing I bet this
is the murder weapon yes but where are
you all going come back here hey you can
I help you inspector uh yes did you
murder anyone dead I saw somebody acting
suspiciously oh yes it was the anonymous
they were nervously looking for
something and left the room with a
kitchen knife
really I heard that Pierrot is to
inherit a lot of money now mr. white is
dead okay I was in the library
both Pierrot and the doctor were there
but I didn't speak to either of them
much are you okay you seem to have some
trouble speaking okay as far as I could
tell from the review that I saw this
game is actually randomly generated so
this story is created um upon the
starting of a new game hello you look
who rather we had I help you inspector
yesterday I was in the flounce around
the Raven and scaramouche were there but
I didn't speak to either of the monkey
oh really to me it doesn't seem normal
to carry a kitchen knife around doesn't
you
well the Harlequin was doing just that
okay the Harlequin he was arguing with
mr. white earlier maybe that means
something okay maybe I don't know so
I've got the kitchen knife does that
mean does that mean that someone's gonna
try to murder me hello mister you
inspected Animists I was in the book
lounge
both the Raven and scaramouche were
there but I didn't speak to either of
the mug okay that's the same thing too
just don't know why the time but I'm
sure I saw the cat with the screwdriver
sometime before the incident I don't
think you're telling the try really
don't know I'm sorry inspector so you
did it I'm gonna murder you what the
hell
it was murdered by who who did it right
it was ills Ian honest wasn't it I knew
he was well then why couldn't I have
done anything about it what the hell
happened I don't know okay alright then
but I had the murder weapon yeah iced
heard the sounds of murder happening
over here wave knows maybe it was over
here Hurst upper jaw hmm someone's been
murdered a well general do open oh I see
I needed to use my journal to be able to
do that well now what's going on here
and I help you inspector hello
scaramouche I was in the blight library
with a Holliman there was somebody else
in the room but I can't remember who it
was mm is Ella big nose of Pinocchio
there you were lying bastard when you
walk in join me lady but I'm sure I saw
the Raiders with a corkscrew sometime
before the incident right I really don't
know I'm sorry inspector you should be
sorry
you don't seem innocent to me but I'm
gonna turn my back to you
I'm guessing that they can't murder me
if I'm in a room with other people in it
that way someone would be like oh that's
the murder unless they're all in it
together I don't know so this game is
kind of like flu but kind of reverse the
guys already dead
her weight guy was already dead never
mind no I'm wrong it's like clue you
what are you can I help you inspector
hello lady
the Harlequin has been a bitter rival
with mr. white for a long time both of
them who've been at each other's throats
for years hmm I never would have thought
it would come to this right hmm I don't
know if it helps but scaramouche was
holding a kitchen knife earlier right
okay what I have to do is I think I have
to find the weapon because I found the
weapon before and then all the sudden it
was sad it was sad that the guy the
anonymous was holding the kitchen knife
and I think that's why none of us guilty
maybe other but I gotta find the murder
weapon before I do what you killed me
last I see you coming towards me yeah I
murder I'm gonna tick off everyone
besides you yep tick tick tick tick way
no not you
we know huh yes ah video is coming
towards me dear inspector you are
invited to attend mr. White's annual
masquerade party formal dress and masks
are required well here we are
uh-huh I suppose I should find mr. white
and thank him for the invitation okay
trying this again now oh is that the
sound of murder I hear well then I
should go see hmm
what oh no murder in here was the matter
who was terrified
ah yes there was definitely a murder
yeah can't I inspect the body isn't it
gonna tell me that he was stabbed
multiple times or something or maybe see
you let me do my thing okay so I gotta
find the murder weapon that's the first
thing that I gotta do someone who
started to play the gramophone hey how
is suspicious actually is an interesting
game I was like playing flu you you you
yeah you're all standing about I might
as well ask some question bomb here Oh
God the mask is creepy I really don't
know I'm sorry you should be too
he doesn't seem normal to carry the
screwdriver does it you know the devil
who was doing just that the della lay
ball with scaramouche and the Piero
Piero and scaramouche you hello madam
time alone a house the anonymous was
holding impossible well I don't think I
see anonymous it's not legit so I tease
death speed that
well you the Dow I help you I heard that
you had a screwed I was on my own in the
library right to me it doesn't seem
normal to carry a nice big around does
it do you well
scaramouche was doing just that okay
both of them but I never would have
thought it would come to this
okay if you say still hurting my back
are you didn't stab me you're coming
after me though that's right you better
back off
hello-o why are you coming after me why
are you coming towards me lady why do
they keep coming towards me like that
it's very disturbing please I just want
to find the murder weapon and so uh
you're all coming towards me you all you
all want a piece of inspector markiplier
well the detective is the all right you
yeah that's right yeah
can I help you inspector yeah Pierrot
the devil was arguing with mr. white
earlier hmm maybe that means maybe to me
it doesn't seem normal to carry a
screwdriver around does it to you hmm
well the cat was doing just that didn't
someone just say that the devil was in
the room talking to
scarily there was somebody else in the
room but I can't remember who it was hmm
very interesting I know like that my
journal doesn't write any of this
seemingly important information now what
are you doing anonymous how can I help
you inspector well I was in the
conservatory talking to the cat there
was somebody else in the room but I
can't remember who it was well you
better start remembering
doosh to me it doesn't seem normal to
hey who's trying the goddamn subtle
driver you're all a bunch well I just
was doing just that you're all a bunch
of liars I really don't know I'm sorry
inspector should be but I'm not keeping
my eye on me no no no you get away from
me you get away from me oh oh well since
I see here
it's covered in blood right I bet this
is the murder weapon
yeah Oh suddenly you don't want a piece
of the mark of liar well oh babe all
right there ah come on
okay let's try this one more time I was
right the first time as soon as I find
the murder weapon someone wants to kill
me dead well looks like he was murdered
in the whatever the hell this room is
that's Oh so suspicious or he all stay
there I'm just gonna explore the rest of
the house looking for a murder weapon
you think that the murder weapon AHA
looks like someone tried to hide them
alive it's covered in blood is covered
in I bet this is the murder weapon
yes hey you hey you [ __ ] you get back
here not you
you how can I help [ __ ] you've killed
me every single time I was in our
ballroom with the Harlequin and
scaramouche scaramouche I don't know why
the time but I'm sure I saw the cat with
a kitchen knife some time before the
entry Lee the cat hey well I'll just go
confirm your story with the cat that no
you're not how can I help you hello
Harlequin I didn't know why at the time
but I'm sure I saw the doctor with a
screwdriver sometime before the incident
right well the screwdriver isn't
important you tell me who you saw with
what mr. big nose devil has been
secretly carrying a nice big that could
have been used as a murder no I don't
think so no the murder weapon was a
kitchen knife because it's covered with
blood there now what I don't know is are
you the cat you think I don't walk it on
me I must stay with other people through
this noise I'm staying with people okay
so the cat is definitely high on my list
of specs hey Jane will you walk towards
me it's very disturbing you're walking
away from me eh
oh where you going
haha hello either can I help you inspect
the doctor please I saw somebody acting
suspicious oh yes it was a Harlequin
they were never seen looking for
something left nicely right well let me
think here is miss your big nose where
did the cat go I'm pretty sure it's the
cat cat book hello jester can I help you
inspector
yes to me it doesn't seem no tonight
life around does it you know
well Pierrot was doing just that the
doctor has never liked mr. white uh-huh
he's been so I need to find someone I
was holding the kitchen knife and both
have the motivation to kill crazy
I loved on the rising cables okay hello
are you the cat yes you are
how can I help where were you I was in
the clowns with Pierrot and the doctor
hmm
how interesting the jesters been
secretly carrying an icepick all night
that could have been used as a murder
weapon
right look either you appear oh I'm
sorry oh you wouldn't know what you
you know I've been alone around with her
I'm in alone with Rome I'm in a room
alone okay I need to find Poirot what do
you owe your the just never mind no aha
now you did gone but they go okay
so I don't think it's the anonymous
Harlequin Raven devil jester scaramouche
of the doctor I think you big nose again
yeah your big nose what are you doing
here how can i murder me inspector tell
me I really don't know I'm sorry
inspector you're no use to me at all I
need to find who it is besides the cat
entero
cat and pee me hello anonymous I think
you're innocent how can I help you
inspector you need to tell me who used
the Harlequin does never like mr. white
he's been in his shadow for a long time
Envy will drive a person crazy I'm not
surprised came to this no not important
not important at all who did you you you
you are you Pierrot
can I help you are where were you I was
in the lounge talking to the doctor
there was somebody else in the room but
I can't remember who it was right the
anonymous has been secretly carrying a
screwdriver all night do you think dude
that could have been used as a murder
weapon right no it couldn't
I really don't know though useless to me
you stay away from me oh I'm in a room
alone so if you kill me don't kill me
don't kill me you're not killing me must
be the cat yes yeah I did it I did it I
did this I did the thing all right that
was really fun I actually enjoyed that
hey this game was randomly generated so
if you want to play it yourself go ahead
and give it a try it's pretty fun it's
like playing clue but you don't need to
play with a duel solving the mysteries
white intriguing a anyway yeah I
seriously had a lot of fun with this
it's a new
take on the other thing it's not like
specifically horror but there is a sense
of creepiness from the way they just
walk towards you with their masks on but
either way I thoroughly enjoyed that
give it a try links in the description
below thank you all so much for watching
50 entities before what with you said
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
what the hell was that
who the hell's daddy know until you get
smarter because I'm usually you're very
dumb you can't tell that I am an octopus
I mean okay